quantitative real-time pcr is a very  sensitive method to detect mrna of  interest in this method we start from  cdna we apply some forward and reverse  primer dntp and  the polymerase cyber green mix so let's  see what really happens inside the tube  inside the tube we have cyber green dye  which when bind to dna gives us  fluorescence in this pcr reaction with  every cycle there would be increase in  dna number hence there would be increase  in the fluorescence  and at a cycle where the fluorescence  reaches beyond the detection limit is  known as cycle threshold or ct  looking at the ct we can estimate how  abundant a cdna is in this case the red  one has a lower city value whereas the  blue one has a higher city value and we  can see that the red one is much more  abundant compared to the blue one  real time pcr could be used for  diagnostic purpose everyone knows about  covet gene expression analysis and copy  number analysis watch the full video to  know more